tipping has become a burden 25 50 75
tips for a takeout order or Starbucks
coffee and don't even get me started on
food delivery apps if you're ordering
something small be prepared to leave a
tip that's worth more than your order
itself it's not just restaurants where
you'll be tipping either nowadays
tipping is commonplace at barber shops
car washes Ubers plumbers and basically
any other service that you can think of
which doesn't really make sense at least
with the restaurants the service is not
the main thing you're paying for you're
paying for the food so it kind of makes
sense to appreciate a great service that
came along with it but in the case of a
car wash or a haircut you're paying for
the service itself so it's kind of odd
that you have to pay 15 or 25 percent
more and inflation has only made this
worse now I'm not trying to suggest that
these people shouldn't be paid a fair
wage but rather that it should be
reflected in The Upfront price this
wouldn't not only make it easier for
customers to gauge just how much they're
spending for a service but it also makes
the income of the service worker much
more stable in fact this is how it's
done in most places outside of the
United States and Canada in countries
like France Denmark and much of Europe a
standard service via 15 is applied to
all bills so there is no awkward
situation where you have to select 15 25
at 35 or no tip as the cashiers watch
you but even this is not ideal ideally
the price of the service is just
included in the product itself as is the
case in Japan China and South Korea in
fact in many of these countries tipping
is actually considered rude and
disrespectful the reason being that if
you're tipping you're basically
insinuating that the business does not
pay them enough which is unfortunately
often the case in America in fact the
minimum wage for service work cruise is
only two dollars and 13 cents per hour
in America but how did things get so bad
how did tipping go from being something
that we used to appreciate exceptional
service to being a burden for customers
and a necessity for employees
taking a look back tipping wasn't always
accustomed in the United States but it
has been this way for quite some time as
American tipping dates back to the
mid-1800s you may have heard that tip
stands for to ensure problemness but
that's just a myth in reality tipping
was something that what the Americans
discovered when traveling to Europe you
see it tipping was a master surf custom
that was invented in Europe during the
Middle Ages Masters would reward
servants with extra cash for excellent
Service as these Americans saw this
practice they latched onto it and they
brought it back to the us being able to
pay extra for a service really showcased
their status and wealth which many of
their egos could not resist but tipping
didn't catch on in America that easily
in fact there was a lot of resistance to
tipping for one people felt that tipping
culture was simply reinforcing social
constructs and classism the upper class
was literally flexing their wealth on
Lower Class citizens but that wasn't the
only concern the other concern was that
tipping was only viable for the rich
eating out was expensive as it is so
expecting middle class and lower class
people to offer tips on top of the bill
seemed Un-American fun fact this
ideology became so prevalent in America
that it actually spread to Europe and
that's why tipping is not standard in
European countries but America would
completely u-turn on this idea after the
Civil War while slaves were finally
freed their job prospects weren't all
that great and most of them would end up
in service-related Industries and these
industries figured that this was the
perfect opportunity to capitalize on
tipping you see these industries figured
that they could get away with paying
former slaves no money technically they
weren't enslaving these people as they
could earn money through tips also they
couldn't theoretically leave at any time
but really it's not like they had
anywhere else to go to so service
Industries became filled with former
slaves that became dependent on tips for
income suddenly dipping was no longer a
way to flex your wealth it became a much
more of a moral issue if you didn't tip
it you were inadvertently supporting
slavery now of course you could argue
that if you buy chocolate or something
you're supporting child labor in some
third world country but it's much harder
to accept that when you're face to face
with a person essentially people who
were against slavery started feeling
obliged to tip regardless of their own
financial position and with that tipping
started becoming a burden
foreign
was a rapidly gaining popularity
throughout the late 1800s and early
1900s this isn't to say that everyone
was happy with the practice in fact a
large portion of the population was not
happy with their practice and we would
see some resistance even from local
governments Georgia for example deemed
that tips were essentially commercial
bribes used to influence service so
naturally ping bribes should not be
customary or encouraged but the issue
was that much of the pushback from these
governments were classic in their own
ways for example in 1915 Six States
would abolish the practice of tipping
this seems like a reasonable move the
policy that should have been introduced
and forced this rule would have been
some sort of minimum wage this way
service workers would no longer be
dependent on tips but instead of
punishing businesses for paying zero
dollar incomes these governments would
decide to punish service workers Iowa
for example ruled that those who
accepted a gratuity of any kind not
those who gave the money themselves
could be fined or imprisoned fortunately
Supreme Courts would step in it and to
deem these rules unconstitutional but
they never proposed a better solution
meaning that things just returned to how
they were in fact they actually became
worse due to a series of laws passed by
Congress starting with the fair labor
standards act in 1938. this legislation
introduced a federal minimum wage a
40-hour work week and a banned child
labor which sounds great but the pitfall
of this act was that it specifically
excluded tipped workers Congress would
simply double down on the stance in 1966
with their so-called tip credit
essentially restaurants were illegally
allowed to pay a sub at minimum wage as
long as tips pushed workers over the
minimum wage Threshold at least
restaurants were required to pay a
percentage of the minimum wage usually
somewhere between 40 and 60 percent but
this too would have changed with time in
1996 Congress ruled that restaurants
only had to pay attempt workers a
minimum of two dollars and thirteen
cents per hour and that's still how it
is across much of the US you would think
that with all these anti-service worker
policies that people would rise up and
protest these changes but the exact
opposite actually happened you see it
the demographics of service industries
were rapidly changing it was no longer a
bunch of former slaves in fact over 50
percent of all waiters are now white
people but it wasn't just the public
that was okay with tipping either many
service workers are actually preferred
the Tipping model you see it wasn't just
the race of service workers that was
changing it was also the age nowadays
service Industries are filled with a
bunch of high school students and young
adults in fact nearly 50 percent of all
waiters are between the age of 20 and
30. for these people doing service work
is often a part-time thing so stability
isn't necessarily the top concern
meaning that they're much more willing
to take a gamble instead of taking a set
minimum wage they're willing to bet on
the general active people during a
Friday night or Independence Day weekend
statistically speaking you're much
better off with a minimum wage but this
hasn't exactly changed the minds of
service workers tipping was no longer
about appreciation or fighting slaver
tipping was now about maximizing revenue
for service Industries and to service
workers leading us to where we are today
foreign
s out that there is a whole science
behind the psychology of tipping and
that there's dozens of research articles
about how to maximize tips these studies
found that waiters should introduce
themselves repeat customer orders give
compliment call customers by their name
Etc but those are all small fish items
the factor that has really propagated
modern tipping culture is none other
than technology the reality is that
technology makes it so easy to spend the
money and has removed so much of the
pain that is naturally associated with
spending money that we're simply way
more willing to spend money take cards
for example consumers are willing to
spend up to 83 more when paying with
their card as opposed to cash so I don't
think you'd be surprised to hear that
the average cash purchase is only 22
dollars while the average card purchase
is a hundred and twelve dollars but by
far the biggest corporate when it comes
to excessive tipping is the infamous
iPad payment terminals for starters
you're paying with a card as opposed to
cash so that's already working against
you but there are several other factors
that push you to tip for example you
don't have to go through the hassle of
calculating a tip you can simply select
a percentage and the iPad will do the
math another technique that these
terminals employ is suggesting a super
high minimum tip this terminal for
example is suggesting a minimum tip of
18 of course you could skip the tip but
what if you thought that the service
actually deserved a 5 or 10 tip you can
either type in the tip manually which
would adjust prolong the awkwardness or
you can just select 18. speaking of
awkwardness this is likely the most
effective method when it comes to
guilting customers into tipping and the
source of most people's frustrations
traditionally any and all tips are left
on the table and waiters don't see the
amount until after the customer leaves
this allows customers to be honest about
how good the service actually was but
when you're forced to select a temp
amount at the register you know that the
cashier is going to see what you
selected but that's not even the worst
part the worst part is that everyone
behind you is also going to see what you
select and you don't want to be that one
person that skips the tip service
Industries have figured out how to
brilliantly leverage technology and peer
pressure you into maximizing tips while
this is a smart move for them this has
simply left customers exhausted and
frustrated with modern tipping
foreign
hearing all this I don't think that
you'd be surprised to hear that there is
a strong and a growing movement against
tipping these people argue that tipping
has nothing to do with showing
appreciation and everything to do with
the fact that many service workers
aren't paid fairly to begin with I mean
it's not like YouTube service workers
who are paid well for example when was
the last time you tipped your pilot or
your lawyer or your accountant or your
doctor these people provide way more
valuable Services than a waiter or a
hotel housekeeper yet you don't tip them
if anything you might send them a thank
you note or buy them chocolate why well
probably because you know that they're
already paid well which supports the
idea that the only reason you tip some
service workers is because you know
they're rated poorly not actually
because you appreciate their service so
theoretically if we paid service workers
better wages we can eliminate tipping
culture in America Pro tippers don't
agree they feel that eliminating tipping
will simply give businesses more
opportunity to gouge prices for example
a 21 meal may rise to twenty four
dollars also this isn't all that
favorable for takeout customers as they
will also have to pay the higher prices
but with that being said it looks like
the rest of the world has made this work
so maybe there's something to it but
only time will tell are you a team
anti-tip or Team Pro tip comment that
down below also drop a like if you think
tipping has gone way too far and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community suggest with your video ideas
and to consider subscribing to see more
questions and logically answer but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one